[Musique]
jean-philippe luce a officiellement pris
ses fonctions en tant que maire de bois
d'arcy
il succède à philippe benassaya élu
récemment député des yvelines
l'ancien premier maire-adjoint a déclaré
souhaiter poursuivre les projets déjà
mises en place par son prédécesseur
la ville de plaisir à renforcer son
service maintien à domicile depuis
l'annnonce du deuxième confinement 68
repas sont distribués chaque jour à des
personnes fragiles afin d'éviter qu'elle
ne se déplacent dans les zones à risque
ce service d'assistance est mise en
place par la mairie pendant toute la
durée du confinement
c'est un soulagement pour les
médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et leurs
adhérents
depuis le samedi 7 novembre un service
de drive permet de venir emprunter
jusqu'à cinq documents à la fois les
créneaux sont adaptés et les emprunts
sont placés trois jours en quarantaine
avant d'être prêté à nouveau face à
l'incompréhension autour du nouveau
protocole sanitaire dans les collèges et
lycées de nombreux enseignants et
parents d'élèves expriment leur
mécontentement ils étaient une
quarantaine ce mardi devant la sous
préfecture de mantes la jolie
une délégation a d'ailleurs été reçue
par le préfet les auto écoles sont
fermées depuis l'annnonce du second
confinement les élèves ne peuvent plus
prendre d'heures de conduite
pourtant les examens au centre de
trappes et rambouillet sont bel et bien
maintenu les taux de réussite ne devrait
cependant pas être pris en compte pour
les auto écoles
enfin jeux de société aux couleurs des
yvelines est désormais disponible
le jeu cirino le chasseur de trésor met
en scène 36 communes pour vivre une
aventure sur plateau à travers le
département
développé par la société familiale créée
à comme games le but est de retrouver
les pièces d'or en s'aidant d'un 10 sur
les cartes des différentes villes
[Musique]
comment